el programa precios cuidados justamente
viene intentar poner algo de control es
un instrumento para intentar poner poner
control en este contexto de espiral
inflacionario en el que se encuentra
argentina en este momento en los últimos
días en la última semana especialmente
tras la renuncia del ahora ex ministro
de economía martín guzmán hubo fuertes
remarcaciones en algunos productos y
algunas consultoras ya están viendo la
posibilidad de que la inflación anual de
2022 esté en el 100 por ciento y no sólo
hubo remarcaciones fuertes sino que en
algunos casos hay faltantes de algunos
productos o insumos porque los
empresarios sienten que no están en
condiciones de ponerles precio o en
algunos casos también hay especulaciones
por ejemplo con una potencial de
evaluación que arrastre hacia arriba aún
más los precios de la economía